28 days after Rihanna's historic Super
Bowl halftime show Riri takes center
stage at the Academy Awards welcome to
Entertainment Tonight already a win for
this year's show but for those
anticipating something to go down like
last year well the Oscars are bracing
for impact
I think you just want to be ready for
anything
crazy things seem to be happening a lot
lately you have to be ready for what may
transpire that you didn't plan
for the first time ever the Oscars will
have a crisis team in place at this
year's ceremony the academy CEO says
it's already run many scenarios and will
be prepared for anything so who's on the
crisis team let's get to work Olivia
Pope consider it handled it's sadly
unavailable but you can likely expect
the group to include security PR experts
Academy members and production Personnel
all of this of course comes in the wake
of Will Smith's Infamous Oscar slap the
actor who was banned from the Oscars for
10 years joked about it on Wednesday in
a new tick tock video did you know that
you can pick any object look at it and
ask it what it thinks of you
speaking of Oscar jokes they flooded
Twitter today focusing on the new crisis
team in action if say cocaine bear
crashed the ceremony or if the killer
doll Megan started a fight in the Dolby
you should probably run
but when it comes to Comedy and timing
Chris Rock might just have the last
laugh
Chris ready for you yep the comedian
who's been testing out material on his
Comedy Tour I'm still kind of processing
what happened is expected to serve up
his long-awaited take on the slap in a
Netflix comedy special March 4th that's
eight days before the Academy Awards the
other big Oscar news breaking today
Mia
Rihanna will perform
[Music]
Collins and Lady Gaga as the only
singers who performed both at the Super
Bowl and the Academy Awards in the same
year motherhood
Oscars Super Bowl I'm still pinching
myself really I'm grateful
[Music]